[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de face aux territoires
aujourd'hui sur tv5monde en direct avec
nos partenaires de ouest france de nice
matin de france antilles et du groupe la
montagne ainsi que 20 minutes m'ont
invité ce matin au moment où le parti
socialiste joue son destin et bien c'est
jean christophe cambadélis bonjour et
mon sens être avec nous vous êtes des
l'ex premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste
toujours membre du parti socialiste
toujours anglais parti socialiste votre
livre sorti il ya un mois hier
aujourd'hui et demain ça pourrait
s'appliquer d'ailleurs à ce qui peut va
arriver au parti socialiste aux éditions
vea première question votre réaction
jean christophe cambadelis sur ce qui
s'est passé hier soir est est-ce qu'au
fond tout cela peut-il être inversé par
un vote des militants ou par un conseil
national qu'elle de ce soir il ya
normalement les statuts indique que ce
sont les militants qui votent de tout
temps il y à une convention dans notre
vocabulaire sur un article de notre
règlement intérieur qui est le 5 2 5 5 2
5 2 5 face à des pans les versions il ya
une convention où les militants votent
mais visiblement la direction du parti
socialiste a préféré le conseil national
qui lui semble plus sûr mais même là on
voit monter partout dans les fédérations
l'opposition à cet accord sur le fond
puis aussi l'opposition faut bien le
dire par rapport à ce qui est octroyé au
parti socialiste comme circonscription
je voyais par exemple dans l'est de la
france des responsables dire on a
bataillé pendant 5 ans et aujourd'hui on
nous dénie le droit de se présenter il
ya une petite chance pour que ça n'aille
pas jusqu'au bout petite chance que
le conseil national qui pourtant
construit autour de l'olivier fort il a
choisi chaque candidat de sa majorité
chaque membre de sa majorité mais il est
possible qu'il y ait à la fois une forte
opposition et qu'il y aussi un vote
compte demandant la direction du parti
de revoir sa copie vous parlez avec
olivier faur vous avez dirigé ce parti a
pas si longtemps alors je parlais avec
olivier forme mais depuis que j'ai pris
position publique contre cet accord ne
nous parlons pas c'est le score d'anne
hidalgo qui fait qu'on en est là
aujourd'hui non je pense que c'est tout
un ensemble on peut pas dire que tout a
commencé avec anne hidalgo ou même tout
a commencé avec holly et fort c'est bien
avant que ne nous sommes pas adaptés ne
sommes pas réformé nous avons pas
reconstruit une offre politique vous
avez une responsabilité bien sûr bien
sûr j'ai une responsabilité comme tous
les responsables du parti socialiste moi
je me défile pas et quand on nous avons
été battus lors des élections
législatives j'ai donné ma démission
parce que j'estimais que je ne pouvais
pas être celui qui est battu et celui
qui porte la rénovation je pensais qu'il
y avait une renaissance possible du
parti socialiste n'a pas été le cas bon
et aujourd'hui on est on est dans cette
situation à partir du moment où dans les
élections que ce soit européenne
municipales régionales départementales
on s'est planqué derrière les
écologistes une personnalité de la
société civile pour ne pas avoir à
assumer notre rôle à la fin les
électeurs disent bon bah voilà vous
voulez pas exister mais font contrer que
vous n'existez pas merci jean christophe
cambadélis d'être notre invité ce matin
vous avez réservé aux déclarations à ce
plateau tout de suite françois xavier le
franc de ouest france nous rejoint
[Musique]
bonjour françois xavier le franc merci
d'être avec nous ce matin alors qu
advient-il du parti de jaurès bonjour
jean christophe cambadélis alors on va
parler du parti socialiste et de ce qui
se passe
en ce moment mais est d'abord une
question l'élection présidentielle nous
remet sous les yeux une réalité c'est
que les gens qui ont du mal aujourd'hui
dans leur vie quotidienne ceux qui se
sentent des classes et se tournent
majoritairement vers le rassemblement
national c'est à dire vers l'extrême
droite on se dit que je reste doit se
retourner dans sa tombe s'il voit cela
comment expliquer que dans une élection
nationale le parti socialiste paraissent
si éloigné de ces gens là alors d'abord
une constatation l'élection
présidentielle une apparence de trois
blocs
qui sont marine le pen
le président de la république et
emmanuel macron et jean luc mélenchon
mais il a une réalité que vous avez
décrite c'est d'un côté les libéraux et
de l'autre les nationalistes qui sont le
débouché d'une espèce de colère sociale
de la gauche n'arrive pas à capter
pourquoi mais une sommes en plein dans
le débat du jour parce que la gauche est
datée
divisé
radicaliser et qu'elle n'est pas en
relation avec les blessures de notre
société elle n'offre pas de débouchés
elle offre une contestation de la
société mais pas un débouché pratique
pas dans les bouches et
programmatique qui permettrait aux
hommes et aux femmes qui sont dans la
plus grande difficulté
venir vers l'eau et nous d'administrer
les choses dans le sens d'une plus
grande justice sociale prenons l'exemple
du monde rural parce qu'ils ferment la
carte du vote front national c'est
souvent la carte des déserts médicaux
par exemple c'est souvent la carte de la
ruralité et dans le monde rural beaucoup
de gens se sentent vraiment déclassé
alors qu'est ce qu'on a raté qu'est ce
qu'on fait ce qu'on a aujourd'hui quand
on est socialiste à dire à ces gens là
est-ce qu'il est encore temps est-ce
qu'on peut encore récupérer les choses
on a vraiment l'impression que des pans
entiers des territoires français sont
complètement oubliés des grands partis
politiques en tout cas ceux de
gouvernement comment expliquer ça alors
il y avait raison d'abord il est
toujours temps de s'adresser à ceux qui
nous envoie un message parce que quelque
part il ya un message derrière ce ce
vote je pense que nous n'avons raté
c'est l'aménagement du territoire c'est
à dire que nous sommes tous des jacobins
prenez tous les les dirigeants
politiques sont jacoba ils ne conçoivent
la politique qu'à partir de paris donc
il faut repartir des territoires il faut
réveiller bien sûr il faut repartir des
prétoires il faut il faut une nouvelle
vague de la décentralisation il faut
rapprocher la délaissée dans la culture
française selon christophe mais s'il ya
une vraie révolution elle est là et il
ya une révolution institutionnelle parce
que le parlement aujourd'hui n'est plus
acteurs de la vie politique et il ya une
révolution à faire en faisant deuxième
étape une troisième étape de la
décentralisation
et en permettant à nos concitoyens de
d'être acteurs de leur territoire et je
termine une seconde et après il ya un
grand débat sur les services publics
honnêtement c'est le grand bilan de la
vague libérale qui a été celle qui a
envahi la france on a réduit les
services publics particulièrement dans
les zones rurales et suburbaines et on
le paye aujourd'hui alors justement le
parti socialiste était au pouvoir il ya
encore pas longtemps il y avait une
réforme des régions est ce qu'on n'a pas
refait pas l'histoire mais est ce qu'on
n'est pas rater une occasion historique
l'a22 réellement donner plus de pouvoir
aux régions on le dit souvent quand on
additionne les budgets des régions 16 on
a à peine celui de la catalogne comme si
on ne faisait pas confiance est ce que
vous avez dit on fait pas confiance aux
territoires finalement le pouvoir très
centralisé a peur de la diversité du
pays c'est un peu ça non bien sûr c'est
cela c'est culturel 1 c'est la culture
française à savoir une culture très
jacobine encore une fois très centralisé
très administrée on ne conçoit la
politique
regardez l'engouement pour la
présidentielle
c'est à dire que c'est l'homme ou la
femme qui décide pour le pays
aujourd'hui le pays la question de la
gauche et du parti socialiste évidemment
mais le pays est suspendu à la décision
du président de la république de nommer
son premier ministre c'est pas
l'assemblée nationale même si elle va
être renouvelée tilt il le fait et donc
on est on a d'une une centralisation
absolue et en plus de cette
centralisation on a une l'administration
centralisée absolue on l'a vu et les
français l'ont vu sur le la sphère du
coc vide comment la france s'est trouvée
dans un seul coup démunis parce que pas
de taxe parce que pas de pas de test
parce que pas de lit et caetera et eon
et ceci est visible dans tous les
domaines et là on nous avons fait fausse
route pendant des décennies par le parti
socialiste à l'initiative de françois
hollande a fait une loi de
décentralisation mais nous sommes restés
à mi chemin nous n'avons pas été
jusqu'au bout dans
la déconcentration des pouvoirs
les questions fiscales de l'histoire
avant 1980 il y avait eu 1977 la grande
victoire des socialistes aux municipales
il est encore aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'élus locaux socialistes il ya aussi il
ya beaucoup de maires socialistes qui
gère notamment des grandes villes et qui
le font plutôt bien qu'ils sont réélus
comment expliquer que il ya cet ancrage
dans la gestion municipale qui semble
encore aujourd'hui une vraie réalité une
force pour le ps et l'incapacité que
semble donner le ps à penser l'avenir du
pays dans son ensemble et non dans sa
diversité une forme d'un visibilité
nationale pour aller dans le voile à
l'est le problème du parti socialiste
c'est que c'est un corps sans tête c'est
à dire que il ressemble à ses filles au
des années 60 70 avant mais c'est à dire
ses avants mitterrand c'est à dire que
nous avons des représentants dans les
collectivités locales qui sont
plébiscitées à chaque à chaque élection
en tant qu' il ya des reculs au petit à
petit c'est évident mais quand il s'agit
de traduire ce que eux ils font
pratiquement
nous ne pouvons pas le faire j'ai
souvenir de cela moi j'avais essayé dans
deux mètres de faire en sorte que dans
le bureau national du parti socialiste y
ait des maires de grandes villes alors
ils ont pas le temps soyons clairs on
l'a vu aussi avec jeanne hidalgo il y
avait cette belle idée de d'une équipe
de deux les maires de france mais ils
n'ont pas le temps de venir à paris de
participer à l'activité donc petit à
petit
le sommet du parti socialiste s'est
distendu ou dégagé ou a pris ses
distances par rapport aux grands élus
qu'est ce qu'ils font les grands élus
quand ils voient un pari et qui voient
ce qui se fait à paris ils ont
l'impression de ne pas être dans le même
parti fondamentalement et ils disent
mais ça c'est des trucs parisien de deux
c'est parce qu'il représente le pays
profond lors il manque peut-être de
grands élus et ce qui ne manque pas
aussi de paysans d'ouvriers de gens de
la vraie vie alors je peux dire qu'ils
les élus sont pas des gens de la vraie
vie mais de s queue leu leu
ce qui manque au parti socialiste est
sans doute à plein d'autres partis c'est
d'être véritablement représentatif de la
société française tout à fait parce que
petit à petit
la formation de notre formation
politique le ps les écologistes même le
parti communiste sont devenus des partis
de centre urbain il ne m'avait plu ni
les banlieues ni les quartiers ni le sub
urbain
les paysans etc et donc vous n'avez plus
il y en a quelques-uns n'exagérons pas
mais vous n'avez plus cette
représentation à la direction du parti
socialiste est donc cette préoccupation
la préoccupation des élites de gauche
est une préoccupation de centres urbains
c'est pas une préoccupation de la
totalité de la société c'est sa grande
réforme qu'il faut introduire dans le
socialisme français le ps ce serait
quelque part embourgeoisé sépare oui oui
bon bourgeoise et dans le sens où la
volonté de transformer le monde est de
transformer la société n'est plus aussi
prégnante que dans les années 60 et les
années 70 mais en même temps la société
a changé et on l'a aujourd'hui il faut
être responsable dans la transformation
mais ça tient aussi à cette coupure
sociologique qui est intervenu au final
on a parlé du monde rural on n'a pas
parlé des territoires ultramarins où la
colère est vive allure elle s'est
exprimée de façon extrêmement
spectaculaire la guadeloupe vote
mélenchon qui vote le pen à 70%
là il ya un pont de territoire français
qui se sent complètement délaissé c'est
quand même inquiétant ou pour la pour la
pour la solidité de la nation oui c'est
très inquiétant parce que là on a une
manifestation brutale de la répression
brutale qui est intervenu sur la coved
et qui a donné l'impression à nos
concitoyens qu'ils étaient sous le talon
de fer d'une puissance coloniale c'est
jean christophe cambadélis 1 l'ex
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
qui est notre invité ce matin on va
regarder écouter chaunu qui est un
dessinateur bien connu et collaborateurs
de de ouest france qui a une question à
vous poser sous forme de dessin c'est la
tradition de cette émission
jean christophe cambadélis comme michel
sardou vous chantez mitterrand relève
toi ils sont devenus fous alors c'est
vrai que jean luc mélenchon c'est un peu
le boa constrictor
livre de la jungle et il est arrivé à
ses fins alors la question je pose elle
n'est pas sur le monde politique mais
sur le monde médiatique qui traite
différemment marine le pen et jean luc
mélenchon surtout quand il s'agit des
liens avec vladimir poutine
alors oui c'est vrai
jean luc mélenchon a eu des sorties
comme il y en a le secret en soutien de
poutine je me souviens qu'il avait dit
ça y va régler ça en quelques en
quelques jours un et qu'il était au
départ dans une étrange
attitude qui visait à mettre sur le même
plan l'agresseur poutine et les
défenseurs à savoir l'otan mais il le
fait avec un anti impérialisme qui est
classique dans une certaine partie de la
gauche il le fait en référence avec les
latino américains qu'il aime
particulièrement où il y avait ce cette
image sur le venezuela et cuba et on a
vis-à-vis de lui une certaine distance
que l'on n'a pas vis-à-vis de marine le
pen il a oublié qu'il a été ministre
jean luc mélenchon oui oui oui il a été
ministre d'antan disait-il le
gouvernement le plus à gauche de la
planète qui était celui de lionel jospin
la une de ouest france france 3 est bien
là une de ouest france ces divisions au
parti socialiste c'est aussi un
éditorial sur le 9 mai l'anniversaire de
la capitulation de l'allemagne un triste
anniversaire qui nous rappelle qu'au
port de l'union européenne il y à la
guerre donc qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'il
faut aujourd'hui à faiblir l'union
européenne la renforcer c'est un des
sujets qui est en discussions
aujourd'hui au sein du parti socialiste
avec les échanges qu'il ya au sein de la
gauche oui et l'accord les divisions
assez votre titre les il est clair que
une grande partie du parti socialiste
même ceux qui ont du bout des lèvres
accepté l'accord sont très faciles à
l'orientation sorte east de l'europe de
jean luc mélenchon dire qu'il ne faut
pas respecter les traités dans le parti
de jacques delors de françois mitterrand
de michel rocard de lionel jospin et de
françois hollande à franges sur ban doit
bien rigoler en entendant ça oui parce
qu'on peut plus protester contre
monsieur norman puisqu'on dit la même
chose que lui au moins dans la forme
mais le fond mais évidemment différent
jean christophe cambadélis est notre
invité ce matin dans un instant de nick
carole directeur des rédactions du
groupe nice matin merci
[Musique]
bonjour denis carot jour merci d'être
avec nous dans un instant nous allons
encore interviewé notre invité jean
christophe cambadélis mais tout de suite
notre partenaire du groupe la montagne
centre france cette semaine c'est le
populaire du centre depuis limoges dans
la vienne et c'est sébastien dubois cas
une question à vous poser jean
christophe cambadélis jean christophe
cambadélis bonjour depuis le début de la
semaine vous êtes opposés aux
discussions de la direction du ps avec
les insoumis sur la question européenne
mais aussi sur des sur un enjeu plus
politique aujourd'hui quelles
alternatives existe-t-il à ces
discussions il y en at il encore où
êtes-vous condamné à devenir finalement
le une force alliée à la république en
marche dont certains chez vous partage
la ligne sociale démocrate alors moi je
suis sur une position de refondation de
la gauche passé de la gauche de
gouvernement avaient été contactés par
emmanuel macron où ses équipes vont donc
sûr que non je ne suis pas dans la
majorité présidentielle
et je ne suis pas dans l'opposition
mélenchonistes je suis dans l'idée qu'il
y a un chemin
populaire
social-démocrate ouvert
un réformiste de gauche
transformant la société de manière
responsable et c'est celui du parti
socialiste mais pour cela il faut
totalement se refonder anthony caro jean
christophe cambadélis on va parler de ce
chemin que vous évoquez mais avant tout
une question très simple le parti
socialiste est mort le parti d'epinay
c'est à dire celui qui a été fondée en
1971 par françois mitterrand est mort et
d'ailleurs c'est assez étonnant parce
que il est mort on le voit bien et c'est
au moment où il meurt qu'il renoue
soi-disant avec l'alliance à gauche mais
quand françois mitterrand faisait
stratégiquement l'alliance à gauche
c'était pour dominer le parti communiste
pas pour être dominé par le parti
communiste est là aujourd'hui c'est eh
bien bon ben voilà on est on n'est plus
rien
on a 25 sièges à défendre et peut-être
déjà 2,5 à gagner et pour cela on
accepte tout et n'importe quoi donc
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui
il faut tout mettre à plat et refonder
un nouveau parti repartir de zéro je le
pense qu'il faut une refondation
profonde du parti socialiste il faut une
nouvelle formation qui pourrait
s'appeler autrement que parti socialiste
après un débat faut-il garder non
socialiste ou pas bon c'est pas le sujet
important mais c'est un parti qui doit
changer de stratégie il ne doit plus
être simplement le parti des salariés
doit être le parti de toute la société
il doit c'est mon ma perspective il doit
s'inspirer du spd en allemagne c'est à
dire un parti à la fois populaire et
social démocrate c'est ça l'avenir de
notre famille politique ce n'est pas de
ressembler à maduro c'est de ressembler
au parti social ou parti social
démocrate allemand est ce qu'il y a une
place pour ça une place entre le bloc
macro nist et la gauche radicale alors
il y a une place à partir du moment où
on cherche à conquérir il y a une place
parce que on sait que le bloc autour d'
emmanuel macron va se fissurer va
s'interroger sur la suite et ils sont
des roches le moment il ne se fissure
pas non mais il va bien dit il va se
fissurer pour l'instant il ne se fissure
pas mais c'est quelque chose qui est
inscrit on voit bien d'ailleurs les
débuts de contradiction entre monsieur
edouard philippe et la direction de l
arm et emmanuel macron ne se
représentera pas et il est aussi
probable pas sûr en mai probable que
mélenchon ne se représente pas donc si
vous avez si vous réfléchissez un peu
plus loin que le moment présent vous
dites que
ce gouvernement et ce pouvoir va être
confronté à la stagflation que ceci va
avoir des conséquences dans le pays s'il
n'y a pas une force qui est capable de
donner une réponse à gauche vous lirez
un espace politique oui qui va qui va
arriver il faut le construire aussi il
ya une offre politique qui permette de
le faire et qui est des gens les jeunes
etc des femmes des gens issus des
quartiers qui soit capable de porter ces
autres autour de quelle ligne politique
l'anc doit il doit j'étais en train de
vous expliquer que l'histoire du parti
socialiste c'est la défense des salariés
l'histoire du spd c'est la défense de la
société dedans il ya les salariés mais
il ya l'intérêt général et ça a l'air de
rien mais c'est une focale comme on dit
ou une orientation qui est totalement
différente alors après ça se déclinent
prendre un exemple vous ne dites pas
parce que vous êtes dans l'opposition la
retraite à 60 ans parce que de toute
façon ça coûte 47 milliards mais comme
vous arriverez pas au pouvoir c'est pas
un sujet pour vous vous dites 62 ans
vous dites que celle ci doit être
financé donc ce n'est pas la réforme de
monsieur macbeth et une réforme partie
gouvernement vous voulez dire oui mais
un parti de gouvernement avec une
vocation de transformation s'il s'agit
pas de soutenir le cours libéral qui est
aujourd'hui dans les instances
gouvernementales et y compris la
dimension transition écologique est ce
que ce nouveau parti
qui petit pourrait-il rassembler au delà
d'un certain nombre de cadres ou de
militants du ps est ce que certains
écologistes modérés ont révocation à le
rejoindre oui à terme il faut commencer
il faut pas dire
je vais attendre que jade au
teat sa formation politique qui
aujourd'hui sur la ligne de madame
rousseau c'est ça aussi on quand on
parle du parti socialiste on parle pas
des écologistes aujourd'hui mme alain
rousseau qui avait été battu lors de la
primaire l'a emporté lors des
législatives le les le la formation
écologiste est totalement sur
l'orientation de jean luc mélenchon sur
toute une série de sujets et
particulièrement sur la question
européenne et donc si vous me permettez
un élément de l'analyse c'est que si on
se projette un petit peu dans l'année à
venir à la fin de l'année prochaine vous
avez les élections européennes
et aujourd'hui on est sur la position de
jean luc mélenchon qui nous demande de
sortir des traités comment va être
présent dans cette élection européenne
on va dire à nouveau à bannans on
s'était trompé dans l'accord avec jean
luc mélenchon on le dénonce maintenant
et jean luc mélenchon va rire aux éclats
et on va être sanctionné c'est à dire
que on se projette pas on n'est pas
capable de construire une stratégie donc
on est là dans le moment présent il faut
sauver quelques parlementaires mais
c'est pas les sauver des parlementaires
c'est offrir une orientation au pays
vous parliez du parti socialiste comme
d'un d'un corps sans tête demain qui
peut l'incarner ce ce nouveau parti je
pense que là chaque fois qu'on s'est
posé ce problème
ça n'a pas fonctionné parce que dès que
vous avez une personnalité les autres
personnalités de notre formation se se
donnent la main on va dire pour empêcher
cette personnalité d'arrivée de tout
temps a jamais on pourrait dire bien sûr
c'est toujours un fonctionne toujours
fonctionné comme ça mais aujourd'hui on
peut pas on est on n'est pas dans la
situation du bipartisme où j'ai connu ça
les heures les délices du bipartisme
j'ai fait partie de deux des équipes de
présidentiable celle de dominique
strauss kahn en son temps celle des
hommes de lionel jospin auparavant
c'est fini ça il faut construire une
offre politique il faut construire une
démarche à partir du moment où il a
construit une personnalité peut le faire
faut prendre l'exemple du parti
socialiste qui
a rompu avec la et ses filles au grâce à
pierre mauroy qui a fait le nouveau
parti socialiste et qui après avoir fait
le nouveau parti socialiste deux ans
plus tard a fait le parti d'epinay avec
françois mitterrand ben c'est la même
démarche aujourd'hui alors demain il y
aura dix ans jour pour jour que françois
hollande était élu président de la
république on voit où le parti
socialiste en est aujourd'hui est ce que
françois hollande aurait dû intervenir
plus tôt pour éviter le naufrage
mais c'est à dire que le naufrage a
commencé de son vivant si je puis dire
c'est peut-être le point de départ mais
le point de départ c'est le conflit
infernal que j'ai vécue de manière
quotidienne
entre les frondeurs qui sont aujourd'hui
à l'initiative autour de l'évier fort
les fondeurs comme laurent baumel ou
d'autres et puis ceux qui ont extrait
mise et la position sociale démocrate
que voulait incarner
françois hollande en la faisant passer
dans le social libéralisme et en disant
de toute façon c'est incompatible donc
dans ce schisme a commencé le résultat
de l'élection présidentielle de 2017
micro la une de nice matin la une de
nice matin trente ans de larmes on
revient sur le drame de furiani avec
notamment le témoignage de nos
journalistes qui étaient sur place qui
ont été blessés à l'époque ce 5 mai 1992
très vite vous aviez une dernière
question je crois très très rapide une
question sur valérie rabault qui
explique avoir été contacté avoir refusé
matignon est-ce qu'elle a eu raison de
le faire
je sais pas ce n'est pas de son fait
elle a pas frappé à la porte de l'elysée
en disant je voudrais produit c'est le
buzz mais c'est ça me parait bizarrement
ça a été démenti par l'elysée mais ça ça
me paraît bizarre cette espèce de d'avis
de recherche du du président de la
république cherche femme plutôt
social-démocrate ouvert à l'écologie
pouvant incarner le la deuxième partie
de mon deuxième quinquennat merci denis
carot directeur des rédactions du groupe
nice matin nous allons nous tourner vers
armelle le goff qui est directrice de la
rédaction de 20 minutes qui est un autre
partenaire de cette émission jean
christophe cambadélis est là une
question à vous poser on écoute bonjour
jean christophe cambadélis est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire dès à présent qui
seront les cadres du parti socialiste de
demain qui sont aujourd'hui les noms qui
comptent et qui compteront pour l'avenir
de ce parti
alors question difficile mais je pense
que des hommes et des femmes comme
carole delga résidents de la région
occitanie italie comme et
michaël delafosse le maire de
montpellier rachik tu es mal fils jean
christophe cambadélis non mais moi jean
christophe cambadélis il a son avenir
derrière lui dont on connaissait pas ça
c'est pas de cela qu'il s'agit même si
je serai présent si vous me parlez des
jeunes à venir oui sébastien roy
d'autres encore qui sont dans l'appareil
du parti socialiste se battent ou des
élus que vous avez vu venir
dans la dernière phase je pense qu'il ya
quelqu'un comme mathieu klein bon il a
beaucoup changé il était avec matheron
après avec taubira aujourd'hui avec
mélenchon mais c'est un père celle d'un
homme de talent
il peut demain être lui aussi en
capacité jean christophe cambadélis est
notre invité bonjour dit m korkmaz dans
un instant nous allons parler de
questions internationales avec vous mais
pas que mais tout de suite syrie
bouttier qui est directeur éditorial de
france antilles notre partenaire sur
place là bas à fort-de-france à une
question à vous poser depuis la
martinique
bonjour jean christophe cambadélis dans
nos territoires le vote de contestation
aux deux tours de l'élection
présidentielle a été très fort pour jean
luc mélenchon au premier tour pour
marine le pen au second tour
qu'est ce que la gauche a raté elle qui
faisait pourtant dégainé scores
importants
dans ces territoires des antilles et de
la guyane
et quelle est selon vous la première des
mesures qu'il faudrait prendre pour
parler à ses électeurs parfois
désorientés les ultramarins alors pour
les ultramarins ben c'est exactement le
même problème que nous évoquions tout à
l'heure pour les suburbains c'est
l'aménagement du territoire avec une
spécificité pour les yeux du tram a et
des spécificités oui oui mariah aux en
guyane et à cagliari partout vous avez
deux les deux mêmes problèmes la
question du logement
et l'adduction d'eau
vous avez le fait que dans ces
territoires le niveau de vie n'a pas
rattrapé celui de la métropole et que
vous avez une distorsion qu'il vienne
fait que s'avance et donc qu'est ce que
vous voulez entendre les gens sont dans
les difficultés sociales voit qu'ils
n'ont pas le même niveau de vie que la
métropole et qu'on les traite de manière
plus dure que en métropole par exemple
encore une fois sur la question de la
coved et bien vous l'avez la
protestation de masse qui n'est pas une
protestation de cristallisation pour
jean luc mélenchon puis pour marine le
pen mais véhicule un moyen de dire ça
suffit maintenant oui on va passer à
l'europe il sort de l'europe et sans
doute en train de se ré écrire après le
vide et la guerre en ukraine il ya deux
jours devant le parlement européen
mario draghi a donné sa vision d'une
nouvelle europe une europe qui serait
élargie à qui voudrait entrer la
moldavie la géorgie est ce que vous êtes
et ce que vous pensez que c'est le sens
de l'europe a le soc dans le sens de
l'europe c'est d'organiser le continent
européen donc il ya des pays qui
manquent évidemment il faut trouver les
moyens de discuter avec eux pour qu'ils
rentrent mais il y à des procédures et
je crois qu'il faut les respecter parce
que sinon on va au bout on va devant des
détentions il ya les convergences
nécessaire pour se retrouver dans leurs
offres qui sont des convergences
économiques et des convergences de type
démocratique ne serait pas pour une
accélération de cette intégration
européenne aux balkans je pense que ceci
est en route mais que ça sert
strictement à rien de précipiter le
rythme il songe également un fédéralisme
pragmatique pour déverrouiller cette
europe qui en temps de crise parfois du
mal à fonctionner ce que le fédéralisme
européen c'est aussi une idée qui
pourrait séduire cette nouvelle gauche
cette refondation de la gauche alors le
cette nouvelle gauche doit être
profondément européenne
elle doit porter le projet européen
mélangez fédéraliste peut-être pas parce
que dans le fédéralisme
il y à une question de supranationalité
et quand on est dans un pays comme la
france évidemment c'est pas sûr que ce
soit le ski le plus beau mais vous
n'êtes pas prêt à changer alors vous
parlez gilles simon a su s'allier du s
je suis prêt je suis mais le spd n'est
pas sur le fait que le fédéralisme le
spd est sur une europe un critère bon
non non non cris des critères qui sont
communs sur un certain nombre de sujets
c'est pas une gestion fédérale de
l'europe mais moi je suis pour une
intégration très fortes européennes
et on le verra dans les élections
européennes je saute un an là que ce
sera le sujet parce que il ya la
question de la défense mais javi il ya
d'autres sujets sur lequel il faut
avancer dans une chance d'intégration
pour pouvoir avancer ce qu'il faut aussi
revenir sur le principe de l'unanimité
pour la prise de décision au niveau
européen je pense que si on pourrait sur
un certain nombre de sujets revenir sur
ce principe parce qu'on voit bien que
c'est un système de blocage si ce n'est
de chantage parce que pour nos auditeurs
et téléspectateurs
c'est assez simple quand vous avez un
sujet qui est sur la table un pays dit
non je vais pas le voter donc il faut
l'unanimité et donc on a envie on vient
le voir en lui disant mais qu'est ce que
tu voudrais d'autres sur les chances sur
quel dans quels domaines par exemple
d'abord dans le domaine économique ça me
semble essentiel je veux bien que dans
le domaine militaire et dans le régalien
il faudra que on nous embarque pas dans
des aventures mais dans le domaine
économique dans le domaine écologique
dans le domaine de
de l'informatique de la révolution de
l'ue matériel on est très très en retard
on prend énormément de retard par
rapport à la chine et par rapport aux
états unis parce que nous avons des
blocages internes même si monsieur
lebreton fait un excellent travail dans
ce sens la semaine dernière le passionne
le patron de frontex a démissionné de
manière un peu fracassante que doit être
la nouvelle politique migratoire de
l'europe d'abord sur le débat n'est pas
sur la politique migratoire îlots de bas
et c'est sur une agence ou pas c'est à
dire comment ou qu'elles sont en tout
cas c'est ses missions voilà c'était les
aînés sont belles tout le monde voit
bien qu'il y a un programme un problème
migratoire et que ceux ci celui ci va
allait être de plus en plus fort
d'autant plus que
avec le résultat de la guerre en ukraine
nous allons avoir des des prix du blé
qui vont flamber dans tout le maghreb et
dans tout le machrek et donc dans
l'afrique noire est donc à nouveau des
mouvements de population donc ce qu'il
faut faire alors est ce qu'il faut ce
qu'il faut faire c'est avoir des
principes clairs ne pas accepter comme
l'a fait madame merkel d'un seul coup
huit cent mille où 1,1 million de
syriens qui traverse l'ensemble de
l'europe et qui sur cette base là font
monter les nationalistes à un niveau
invraisemblable mais ne pas être aussi
sur la position de des nationalistes qui
disent bas mettons défaire barbelés tout
au long de l'europe donc il y a
d'abord la nécessité d'assécher les
mouvements ensuite d'avoir de ce qu'on
appelle des hotspots c'est à dire des
lieux dans un certain nombre de pays
limitrophes pour accueillir les migrants
mais c'est ce que c'est ce qu'elle
n'aura pas déjà fait avec la turquie et
sortants on a bien vu dans mais aussi un
levier on sait pas c'est parce qu'on a
fait avec la turquie et on a négocié
avec la turquie contre beaucoup d'argent
que ces derniers s'occupent
des migrants on l'avait fait avant avec
monsieur kadhafi s'est passé pas une
solution c'est d'abord à sécher les
problèmes puis les contenir puis les
intégrer et ceux qui ne peuvent pas être
intégré les reconduire donc c'est ma
théorie c'est bien bien bien accueillir
bien reconduit à sécher c'est à dire
c'est l'aide
à tous points de vue des pays d'afrique
et du maghreb pour que l'hymne et nous y
avons intérêt et c'est ça que je
comprends pas nous avons intérêt à
augmenter le niveau de vie c'est le
problème de l'europe c'est que on est un
énorme problème sur la migration pour
ceux qui viendraient du sud mais on n'a
pas de politique euro méditerranéenne et
si l'europe veut aujourd'hui être au
coeur des préoccupations des européens
une politique européenne et la politique
africaine on a bien vu ces derniers
temps un sentiment anti français se
développer énormément dans les pays
d'afrique francophone est ce que le
parti socialiste a aussi un peu sa
responsabilité dans ce partout dans ce
sentiment anti françaises le parti
socialiste ne peut pas avoir toutes les
responsabilités sur tous les sujets même
si il a une part de responsabilité mais
je croix bleue honnête dans cette
refondation du parti socialiste est ce
qu'il y à aussi matière à revoir sa
politique africaine on a bien sûr c'est
évident mais la politique
méditerranéenne comme la politique
africaine il faut il faut la revoir dans
une sens dans un sens de plus de
coopération mais les président et
premier ministre de gauche ont été un
peu quand même dans ce sens merci
démarre à vaumas jaurès à tv5 monde jean
christophe cambadélis martine aubry
appelle à valider l'accord entre le
parti socialiste et les insoumis là dans
un communiqué il ya quelques minutes
vous à vous étonne non ce m'étonne pas à
partir du moment où olivier faure avait
fait un point de fixation dans la
négociation avec les la france insoumise
de la circonscription de monsieur vicaut
qui est un très proche de martine aubry
vous dire que c'est de la tambouille
interne ça
donc oui parce que elle avait manifesté
son désaccord sur la question européenne
votre avis sur le parcours on a parlé
tout à l'heure avec des carreaux de
françois hollande qui semble-t-il vous
dirai où aurait pu vouloir devenir
député qui intervient constamment en
contre 1 d'emmanuel macron votre analyse
sur françois hollande que vous
connaissez bien vous avez fait sa
campagne et vous avez été premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste sous son
mandat comment vous voyez à françois
hollande et vous d'abord françois
hollande se désole de la situation de sa
propre formation politique c'est ce qui
pèse au fond est-ce que sa parole porte
je crois parce que sinon on invite vous
croyez
mais parce que le en y alliant n'a rien
pour le ya pas de d'éléments qui nous
permettrait de gérer l'accord qui s'est
signée par exemple un énorme et ça veut
pas ça veut pas dire que c'est lui qui
décide pour les uns et les autres la
plupart des dirigeants politiques
actuels du parti socialiste ne prennent
pas leurs ordres chez françois hollande
mais franchement le mandat est un ancien
président de la république de ce point
de vue là il faut le respecter moi je le
respecte je ne suis pas de ce type comme
alibi sur 10 il a trahi la gauche c'est
pas ma vision sur quoi il faudrait vous
dire sur quoi
mais je pense que françois hollande est
assez mal traité par le président de la
république
président de la république et plus
aimable ont valu devrait lui confier une
mission oui voilà il est plus aimable
entre guillemets dans ce club des
anciens très fermé des anciens
présidents de la république avec nicolas
sarkozy dieu avec
françois hollande dont il a été le
collaborateur et les je crois tu eu et
il y a là une petite tension qui
nécessiterait dans ce deuxième
quinquennat qu'elles soient soulevées
jean christophe cambadélis
allez vous créer un nouveau parti moi je
souhaite bon mais ça ne se décrète pas
je crois que le parti socialiste dans
son prochain congrès nous allons gestion
radical puisque j'ai dit qu'il fallait
qu'il s'auto d'issole
secret une nouvelle formation politique
parce que le débat est assez s'il ne le
fait pas lui même est ce que vous oui
s'il donnait attaquera ce moment là oui
j'essaierai de rassembler les partisans
pour le faire parce que je ne suis pas
sur l'orientation de jean luc mélenchon
qui nous propose de sortir de l'europe
de sortir de l'otan de sortir de l'om
c'est vous rendez compte l'article 47 de
son programme gagne assure mondiale du
commerce l'organisation mondiale r c'est
à dire que nous serions avec la corée du
nord et deux autres pays c'est tout
sortir de l'om sait et personne n'en a
parlé jusqu'à présent c'est pas possible
on peut pas être sur cette orientation
là il faut avoir une gauche de principes
de valeurs de transformation qui soit
les élections européennes sont le temps
idéal politiquement pour créer ce
nouveau par traoui je pense que les
élections européennes seront un moment
important pour soi faire ce nouveau
parti parce que le parti socialiste en a
décidé de se dégager de
l'intégration mélenchonisme soin de
créer les conditions d'une nouvelle
formation politique donc vous avez une
stratégie à huy me sens oui vous avez un
nom pour ce nouveau parti non non non
j'aime jeudi quand j'ai des goûts et
j'ai dit comme cela quand on m'a posé la
question que je voyais bien un mouvement
populaire sociale n'est alors pas le mot
socialiste de randa compris si ça peut
être mais je veux dire vu qu'on va pas
bloquer le débat sur
le marketing
cette nouvelle formation est et ils
décideront on décidera de ce qu'elle
sera mais avant il faut faire obstacle à
l'accord il faut défendre les
socialistes libre c'est à dire ce qu'ils
se maintiendront dans ces élections
législatives et puis après il faut aller
au congrès du parti socialiste ait
tranché ce désaccord stratégique c'est
pas la première fois dans l'histoire de
la gauche qu'il y en a eu hier
aujourd'hui et demain au fond c'est tout
un programme d'un futur parti merci jean
christophe cambadélis ex premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste on se
retrouve jeudi prochain bien sûr d'en
face aux territoires avec nos
partenaires de ouest france de nice
matin de 20 minutes de france antilles
et du groupe la montagne aura tous ces
beaux gentils merci merci jean
christophe cambadélis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]